Ich hab Gänsehaut.
Nur keine gute.
Hatte niemanden,
mit dem ich darüber reden konnte.
Man ist kurz zur Toilette gegangen
und hat kurz mal heulen können
für ein, zwei Minuten
während man sich erleichtert hat.
Stopp!
Bevor ihr vor lauter schlechter Laune
aussteigt, wartet kurz.
Das Thema "Pflege" scheint
in der Zeit etwas breitgetreten
oder fast schon totgetreten.
Die Situation hat sich
doch jetzt endlich entspannt.
Oder nicht?
Ja, sie hat sich entspannt.
Aber nur von der Coronasituation.
Sie hat sich entspannt von ...
Ach du heilige Scheiße! Fuck!
Auf ... einfach nur noch scheiße.
Während Corona musste man
immer wieder erklären,
dass auf den Intensivstationen
fehlendes Personal das Problem ist.
Doch dieses Problem ist leider alt.
Hier ein Beitrag vom NDR von 2018.
"Ja, wir gehen jetzt in einen Raum,
der ebenfalls unbenutzt ist."
"Wo Sie Wärmebetten sehen,
Perfusoren, Kleinkinderbetten."
"Und das Pflegepersonal-Problem ...
macht daraus eine Abstellkammer."
(Mai:) Es könnte
noch schlimmer werden.
2019 sorgte eine Befragung
von rund 2.500 Intensivpflegekräften
für diesen Titel:
37 Prozent der Befragten gaben an,
dass sie innerhalb
der nächsten fünf Jahre
ihren Beruf verlassen wollen.
Sobald ich kann,
bin ich aus diesem Beruf weg.
(Mai:) Das ist Ricardo Lange,
Intensivpfleger in Berlin.
Vielleicht kennt ihr ihn,
er ist derzeit viel
in der Öffentlichkeit.
Er nutzt die Aufmerksamkeit
und spricht
über die Missstände in der Pflege.
Ich hab selber
mehrere TV-Anfragen gehabt,
die zum Sommer hin
komplett abgesagt wurden
aus Desinteresse, weil das Thema
nicht mehr im Fokus ist.
Dabei gibt es nur wenige Themen,
die so wichtig sind,
und die so viele von uns
direkt betreffen.
Jeder einzelne von uns, auch ich,
kann und wird eventuell mal
auf Pflege angewiesen sein.
Pflege hat viel
mit Menschenwürde zu tun.
Ganz banales Beispiel:
Man liegt im Bett,
ist schon etwas älter,
körperlich nicht mehr
so auf der Höhe,
dass man vieles
nicht mehr alleine machen kann.
Und man muss Stuhlgang lassen,
oder man muss mal Pipi machen.
Und das ist einfach so,
wenn man krank ist,
passiert's auch ins Bett,
in die Windel.
Wenn man dann stundenlang in seinen
eignen Ausscheidungen liegen muss,
bevor der nächste Pfleger
oder Pflegerin kommt,
um einen da rauzuholen,
glaubt mir,
ich seh das öfter auf Arbeit,
das ist kein Zustand,
den man sich annähernd wünscht.
Das ist eines dieser Themen,
die eigentlich ständige
Aufmerksamkeit verdient hätten.
Falls ihr dieses Video am Ende
gut oder hilfreich findet,
teilt es bitte.
Holt euch 'nen Tee,
wir steigen durch.
(Lebhafte Musik)
Kurz vorweg:
Die Probleme in der Pflege
sind so vielfältig leider,
dass wir ihnen in einem Video
nicht gerecht werden können.
Wir haben uns zusammengetan
mit "DIE DA OBEN!".
Jan hat sich die Wahlprogramme
der verschiedenen Parteien angeschaut
und analysiert, was sie konkret
für die Pflege tun wollen.
Findet ihr
in der Infocard oder Endcard.
In der öffentlichen Diskussion
um die Pflege
geht es oft um die Entlohnung.
Tatsächlich sind ausgerechnet
systemrelevante Berufe
unterdurchschnittlich bezahlt.
Nicht nur das, sie genießen auch
unterdurchschnittliches Prestige,
Ansehen in der Gesellschaft.
Systemrelevant, aber schlecht bezahlt
und wenig angesehen.
Hier liegt also eine Schieflage,
ein Ungleichgewicht vor,
das natürlich zu Frust
und Unzufriedenheit führt.
Es gibt noch mehr Faktoren,
die in dieses Gleichgewicht
reinspielen,
die's verstärken
oder abmildern können.
Das schauen wir uns genauer an.
Wirst du für deine Anstrengung
angemessen belohnt?
Bekommst du raus, was du reinsteckst?
Das ist die Frage,
die hinter dem ERI-Model steht.
ERI steht für:
Oder auf Deutsch:
Wenn Anstrengung und Belohnung
im Ungleichgewicht sind,
führt das nicht nur zu Frust,
sondern langfristig auch
zu chronischem Stress
und erhöht das Risiko
für bestimmte Krankheiten,
von Burn-out
über Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
bis hin zu Depressionen.
Es gibt einen ERI-Fragebogen,
den man
in soziologischen Studien einsetzt.
Er fragt folgende Sachen ab:
Das Ausmaß der Anstrengung,
die ein Job verlangt.
Die Belohnung,
hier gibt's drei Unterpunkte:
Und zuletzt ein spannender Punkt
namens "Overcommitment".
Erklär ich gleich.
Wir gehen mal gemeinsam
diesen Fragebogen durch.
Ihr könnt reflektieren,
wie's in eurem Job aussieht.
Wir wollen von Ricardo wissen,
was seine Erfahrungen sind.
Ich hab in meinem Beruf
'ne sehr hohe Verantwortung.
Und man hat ja an sich selber
auch so ein gewisses ...
einen Anspruch,
seine Arbeit ordentlich zu machen.
Und der Spahn hat selber vorgegeben,
dass ein Intensivpfleger
im Tagesgeschäft
zwei schwer kranke intensivpflichtige
Patienten betreuen sollte.
Ist leider nicht immer möglich
oder fast nie.
Wir betreuen
drei oder vier Patienten.
Das führt dann dazu,
dass ich meine Aufmerksamkeit
auch auf drei bis vier Patienten
aufteilen muss.
Dann haben wir manchmal
wirklich Patienten,
die sind so krank, dass man
von diesem Bett nicht wegkommt.
Jetzt hat man aber noch
zwei oder drei andere Patienten,
die sind genauso schwer krank.
Und die fallen dann eben runter.
Man weiß eben gar nicht mehr,
wie man das schaffen soll.
Oftmals ist es so, dass man
immer wieder einspringen muss.
Also, an dem Wochenende,
wo man frei hätte,
hat man eben doch nicht frei.
Und ja, man gibt
sein eigenes Sozialleben auf,
um eben dem Patienten
helfen zu können.
Meine Meinung zur Wertschätzung ist,
unabhängig von der Welt draußen,
dass wir Pflegekräfte uns selber
anfangen sollen, wertzuschätzen.
Wir haben auch eine Gesundheit.
Wir haben auch ein Privatleben.
Wir müssen so selbstbewusst werden,
auch mal Nein zu sagen.
Erst wenn wir
uns selber wertschätzen,
können wir das auch
von anderen einfordern.
Also, für die Arbeit,
die ich als Intensivkrankenpfleger,
aber mit Sicherheit
auch jede andere Krankenpflege
in anderen Fachabteilungen,
machen muss,
die Verantwortung, die man hat,
den Stress, den man hat,
die soziale, ich sag mal,
Isolation, die man zum Teil hat ...
Weil man hat ja
nicht wirklich 'n Sozialleben,
weil man immer dann arbeitet,
wenn andere frei haben und umgekehrt,
ist die Bezahlung in meinen Augen
nicht angemessen.
Wär sie denn angemessen,
würde es genug Menschen geben,
die diesen Beruf machen.
Wie jeder weiß,
gibt es einen hohen Personalmangel.
Die Aufstiegschancen
sind in der Pflege super,
wenn man sie
nutzen möchte und auch nutzt.
Aber dazu braucht man natürlich
auch genug Personal.
Weil man muss wissen, dass jeder,
der jetzt wie ich, am Bett steht
und 'nen Studiengang besucht,
und wird etwa Pflegedienstleitung,
der fehlt ja am Bett.
Und deswegen sind auch die Kliniken
'n bisschen sparsamer damit.
Weil jede Pflegekraft,
die sich weiterbildet
und weg vom Bett geht,
fehlt nachher am Ende.
Der Pflegeberuf ist
in der Sicherheit,
was die Anstellung angeht, super.
Weil weiß ja bestimmt jeder,
dass Pflegekräfte überall fehlen.
Und somit wird man immer
'ne Stelle irgendwo finden.
Problem ist aber,
dass man 'ne Stelle finden muss,
wo man sich auch wohlfühlt.
Weil die Umstände vor Ort
nicht dazu führen,
dass man längerfristig
dort bleibt heutzutage.
Kurze Worterläuterung, weil's keine
gute deutsche Übersetzung gibt:
"Commitment" ist Englisch,
heißt auf Deutsch so viel wie:
Hingabe, Einsatz,
Leistungsbereitschaft,
aber auch Verpflichtung.
Also, wenn ich commitet bin,
bin ich voll am Start,
mit vollem Einsatz dabei.
"Overcommitment" bedeutet,
ich bin zu commitet,
ich mach mehr, als man von mir
verlangt, mehr als ich sollte.
Beziehungsweise ich bin
so commitet mit meiner Arbeit,
dass sie mich nie loslässt,
auch nicht im Privaten.
Ein ganz prägendes Ereignis
jetzt in der Coronapandemie:
Ähm ...
mein Hund war krank.
Ich wollte mich am nächsten Tag
von der Arbeit abmelden,
weil's meinem Hund
wirklich nicht gut ging.
Wir waren auch beim Tierarzt
und hätten am nächsten Tag
wieder zum Tierarzt gemusst.
Da teilte man mir am Telefon mit:
"Ricardo, bitte komm mal."
"Da fehlen schon so viele Leute,
wenn du nicht kommst,
ist alles vorbei."
Ja, man hat seine eigenen Bedürfnisse
wieder runtergeschraubt,
ist zur Arbeit gefahren.
Um neun Uhr
wär der Tierarzttermin gewesen,
aber um acht Uhr
bekam ich die Nachricht,
dass mein Hund verstorben ist,
Ich hatte an diesem Tag Frühdienst.
War ein Sonntag,
werd ich nie vergessen.
Hatte vier Patienten zu betreuen
statt zwei, also wirklich viel.
Und musste diesen harten
Schicksalsschlag runterschlucken,
musste konzentriert
bei der Arbeit bleiben,
hatte niemanden,
mit dem ich darüber reden konnte.
Man ist mal kurz zur Toilette
gegangen und hat kurz mal
heulen können
für ein, zwei Minuten.
Während man sich erleichtert hat.
Und musste dann wieder
hochkonzentriert zur Arbeit gehen.
Und das Ganze ist jetzt ...
ja, fast 'n Jahr her.
Und ich fühle mich
heute noch als Verräter,
weil man den besten Freund,
den man hat,
also der Hund ist ja für viele
der beste Freund
und 'n Familienmitglied,
in seiner schwersten Zeit
im Stich gelassen hat.
Weil man auf der anderen Seite
seine Kollegen
nicht im Stich lassen wollte.
Weil man die Patienten
Und ... ja.
Dat is für mich wirklich
'n sehr prägendes Ereignis.
Wo ich auch heut noch mit zu tun hab.
Ich kann jetzt offen drüber sprechen,
weil ich schon mehrmals
drüber gesprochen habe,
aber es fiel mir anfangs schwer.
Diese Überladung an Arbeit,
an Stress
führt eben dazu,
dass man in den Urlaub geht.
Und jeder, der Urlaub hat,
der freut sich.
Aber ich geh in den Urlaub,
und ein Tag ist vorbei, ich denk
nicht, schön, endlich Urlaub,
sondern ich sage mir, es ist
schon wieder ein Tag Urlaub rum,
ein Tag,
den du weniger frei hast.
Und der dir von deiner Freizeit
flöten geht.
Und man hat wie so 'ne Sanduhr,
die langsam abläuft,
wo man genau weiß,
morgen musst du wieder arbeiten.
Man kann den ganzen Urlaub
nicht richtig entspannen,
weil man immer wieder Angst
vor der Arbeitsbelastung hat.
Weil man ganz genau weiß,
bis zum nächsten Urlaub
wird noch 'ne Weile vergehen.
Man muss wissen, dass man
immer emotional erpressbar ist,
weil man 'ne Verantwortung hat
für Leben und für Gesundheit
von Menschen, die auf unsere Hilfe
angewiesen sind.
(Mai:) Bei 'nem Bürojob
kommt's öfter vor,
man geht abends ins Bett
und denkt:
Was mach ich eigentlich,
was hat meine Arbeit für einen Sinn?
Das Gefühl hast du
wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Doch.
Manchmal frag ich mich selber,
was hat meine Arbeit für einen Sinn?
Wenn man seine Arbeit nicht so
erfüllen kann, wie man's gern hätte.
Also ...
warum bin ich Intensivpfleger?
Ich möchte mich
um schwerstkranke Menschen kümmern.
Wenn ich aber auf Arbeit bin
und meinen eigenen Anspruch
jedes Mal verraten muss,
ich muss quasi meinen
eigenen Anspruch runterschrauben,
muss mitansehen,
wie Patienten darunter leiden,
dann frag ich mich
doch häufig schon,
wo ist der Sinn deiner Arbeit?
Warum machst du das noch?
Sobald ich kann,
bin ich aus diesem Beruf weg.
Wenn man das so hört,
fragt man sich fast,
wie es überhaupt sein kann,
dass ja immer noch
die Mehrheit der Pflegekräfte
nicht aufhören will.
Das liegt daran,
dass der Pflegeberuf
für die Menschen,
die ihn ergreifen, Menschen,
die gern anderen Menschen helfen,
grundsätzlich ein erfüllender
und schöner Beruf ist.
Deswegen wünschen ich mir, dass ich
den Job noch lange machen könnte.
Was mich freuen würde, wäre,
wenn das zum Teil in diesem Video
noch mal deutlich werden würde,
dass das ein toller Beruf ist.
(Mai:) Das sind Prof. Katja Boguth
und Prof. Johannes Gräske
von der ASH Hochschule in Berlin.
Beide waren viele Jahre selbst
als Pflegekräfte tätig.
Das ist das Manuskript einer Studie,
die sie frisch eingereicht haben.
Es handelt sich
um eine wissenschaftliche Befragung
von Pflegekräften, etwa zu deren
Anstrengungs-Belohnungs-Balance.
Unter den knapp 2.700 Befragten,
hier ging's nicht nur
um Intensivpflege,
sondern um alle Pflegeberufe,
denken knapp 40 Prozent
darüber nach, aufzuhören.
Ein Krisenszenario.
Auch das ist ein Szenario, was sich
viele nicht vor Augen führen,
aber für mich hat der Pflegeaufwand
'n ähnliches Ausmaß
wie der Klimawandel,
auf den wir zusteuern.
(lachend:) Aber ich glaub, das ist
vielen noch gar nicht so bewusst.
(Mai:) Die Probleme, die wir heute
schon sehen, werden nur schlimmer,
weil unsere Gesellschaft
immer älter wird.
Laut dieser Prognose
kommen im Jahr 2060
auf 100 Menschen
zwischen 20 und 64 Jahren
85 Menschen,
die über 65 Jahre alt sind.
Das betrifft eben dann auch ...
sicherlich nicht mehr meine
Generation, sondern die der Jüngeren.
Die dann auch viele Menschen ...
pflegerisch zu versorgen haben,
seien es die eignen Eltern
oder in der Nachbarschaft,
Freunde, weil es einfach keine
ambulanten Pflegedienste mehr gibt.
Oder auch keine
stationären Pflegeeinrichtungen.
Wenn dieser Beruf
nicht unterstützt wird,
dann landet das im Prinzip
bei der Gesellschaft.
Ein kleiner ambulanter Pflegedienst
mit zehn Pflegenden,
was wollen die zehn Pflegenden
da machen?
Wenn die sich nicht
alle einig sind und sagen,
wir kündigen jetzt alle gemeinsam,
wird sich nichts ändern.
Und das machen sie nicht.
Das wird ausgenutzt.
Auch in Tarifverhandlungen,
weil Gewerkschaften
und Arbeitgeberverbände wissen,
Pflegende streiken
typischerweise nicht.
Also in Deutschland.
- Weil die ...
In Deutschland, ja.
Die beiden machen sich
übrigens keine Hoffnung,
dass die Politik von alleine
was ändert.
Sie sagen, ohne Druck
von den Pflegekräften
passiert gar nichts.
Ich bin seit vielen Jahren
berufspolitisch unterwegs.
Und ich verzweifle zum Teil ...
Aber auch nicht nur
an den Politikerinnen und Politikern,
sondern auch teilweise
an der eigenen Berufsgruppe.
Ja, also diese Leidensfähigkeit
so einerseits und
auf der anderen Seite dann aber ...
so mit den Füßen abzustemmen
und zu gehen.
Das ist, glaub ich,
das ganz große Problem.
Sehr wichtiger Punkt.
Denn zwischen alles erdulden
und alles mit sich machen lassen,
und die Schnauze komplett voll haben
und gehen ...
dazwischen ist ja noch was.
Nämlich für sich einstehen.
Sich für seine Interessen
starkmachen,
sich organisieren
in Gewerkschaften,
die unter anderem für bessere
Gehälter und Arbeitszeiten kämpfen.
Und in Berufsverbänden,
in Pflegekammern,
die für die fachlichen
Arbeitsbedingungen,
die Qualität der Pfleger einstehen.
Die Diskussion, die ich früher
noch auf Stationen geführt habe:
"Warum kommt keiner
von der Gewerkschaft und sagt,
wir brauchen 1.000 Euro mehr
im Monat?"
Na ja, weil ihr nicht
in der Gewerkschaft organisiert seid.
Warum soll die das tun?
Dieses Selbstverständnis
ist schwierig ...
zu verändern im Pflegeberuf, ne?
Das ist ... es wird immer gewartet,
dass irgendwer anders kommt
und etwas verbessert.
Das passiert aber nicht.
Ich war fassungslos,
wir hatten in einigen Bundesländern
es ja erreicht, dass es ...
berufliche Pflegekammern gab.
Und die sind
ja dann auch in Umfragen
im Nachgang
von der Berufsgruppe wieder ...
selber abgeschafft worden.
Und hier wird mir
auch noch mal bewusst,
wie wenig hier
vielleicht auch Zusammenhänge
verstanden werden.
Immer wenn wir einspringen,
nicht nur ich,
sondern auch meine Kollegen
und Kolleginnen,
halten wir das System, was
seit Jahren nicht mehr funktionieret,
am Laufen,
deswegen wird sich nichts ändern!
Es ist ja eigentlich nur logisch,
dass Menschen,
die eine Erfüllung darin finden,
anderen Menschen zu helfen,
nicht besonders gut darin sind,
für sich selbst einzustehen.
Aber, liebe Pflegekräfte,
ihr müsst es tun.
Das ist die harte Realität, auch wenn
es eigentlich 'ne Sauerei ist.
Es ist 'ne Sauerei,
dass ihr für euch kämpfen müsst.
Es sollte eigentlich im Interesse
von jedem Einzelnen von uns sein,
dass die Bedingungen
für diesen wichtigen Beruf
gut sind.
Hier muss endlich die Politik ...
an die Arbeitsbedingungen ran.
Moin, hier ist Jan
von "DIE DA OBEN!",
dem Politikformat bei "funk".
(Mai:) In der Politik wird viel
geredet, aber was sind die Pläne?
Was will man tun,
das hat Jan für euch analysiert.
Wenn ihr genau wissen wollt,
wie die Pflege
laut unseren Parteien
in Zukunft aussehen soll,
klickt hier
und checkt mein Video aus.
Schaut unbedingt vorbei,
schreibt in die Kommentare,
was ihr persönlich aus
dem ERI-Fragebogen mitnehmen konntet.
Wir sehn uns bald, bleibt sicher!